well more bad news for President Biden
as he bolts to Camp David for the
holiday weekend it is not just the rocky
debt ceiling talks or a growing
Republican primary field that he's got
to worry about it's his own party and
the American people a new Fox News poll
shows that the president is facing
serious competition from Democrats he
only captures 62 percent of the vote
against Challengers Robert F Kennedy Jr
and Marianne Williamson and worse 67
percent of Americans view a Biden
victory in 2024 as a quote disaster or
setback for America the media pointing
out that President Biden does face an
uphill battle
horrible news horrible for Joe Biden and
our new CNN poll while the president
leads his Democratic competitors by a
huge margin two-thirds of all of the
American people surveyed 66 percent of
the public say that a Biden Victory
would either be a setback or a disaster
for the United States it's not an
outlier right so our CNN poll had
Kennedy at 20 percent we've had two Fox
polls out in the last month one had him
at 16 the other one had him at 19
Kennedy is putting up a far more
impressive showing than I would have
thought when he first entered the race
and with numbers that bad critics say
the president isn't doing himself any
favors by avoiding the media it's been
more than a month since the president
announced that he was going to run for
re-election and he's still yet to travel
out to hold a campaign event he's been
very stingy with press conferences too
but the White House insists the
president's out there
I feel strongly by saying this the
president is certainly not media shy uh
he would disagree with that that
characterization of him we might not
okay while the president stays away
Republicans are going on offense and
attacking his presidency
we have a president who is a listless
vessel not energetic and not dealing
with the key challenges that are facing
our country but it does not have to be
this way our decline as a country is not
inevitable it is a choice and I think we
can choose a better pathway under
President Biden
our nation is retreating away from
patriotism and Faith the radical love is
pushing us into a culture of grievance
instead of a culture of greatness
okay lots to discuss there but Rachel
let's start with this the White House
saying he's available to the media and
he would take issue with any of us
calling him press shy
well it's obvious he's not out there I
mean and who would I mean the the stuff
you were reading said well he's out
there but you know it's good for him if
listen he is not ready for prime time
right now he's made too many mistakes
it's better to keep him out it's worked
before it did I mean it worked in 2020
but Jessica we're over covid now he's
gonna have to get out there and he's
doing that with really negative numbers
um from his own party I mean to be the
sitting president and have like 40 of
your party looking to somebody else is
not a good start
no it's not and I definitely thought
that this would Whittle away it may
still I mean we're pretty far out
um from general election time and from
when the debates would technically start
even though they're not going to be
happening do you think that they should
have the decency debates because listen
I know it's out there but but there have
been a number of Democrats who stepped
forward to say like I think we should do
it so I always think that it's best to
be out as much as possible I've said
that about President Biden I think he
does really well in interviews honestly
and I think that he shows you know his
breadth and depth of understanding of
the job and what he did as a senator and
can talk about vice president and all of
it well I think he should do more I
think he should have more press
conferences but to the point about the
debates
this would be completely controverting
tradition in terms of having them the
RNC did exactly the same thing with uh
Donald Trump they actually declared even
earlier than the DNC did in terms of
blocking debates for President Biden
Ronald McDaniel came out and said we're
supporting uh Donald Trump there were
other candidates
um in the field like a mark Sanford a
bill weld they didn't get their chance
to do it in some states didn't even
um hold primaries they just walked
Donald Trump to the Finish Line there so
I it's a bit hypocritical when people
throw that at the Democrats but
obviously these numbers aren't fantastic
and something has shifted and I think a
good amount of it is actually around
what's going on with the debt ceiling
fight because I was looking back at the
polling for President Obama when he had
the same fight and when the American
public was asked who will you blame if
we default it was Republicans by a plus
10 margin now if we default and I saw
Janet Yellen just push the definition so
hopefully we'll get something done but
it's President Biden plus three or four
points that he would be the right
responsible so something is Shifting in
the American psyche key in terms of who
they're holding responsible for it and
the perception that they have of
Republicans they're obviously think to
some degree that McCarthy is the one
that is out there doing well or
negotiating or you can't listen yeah he
had a hard start getting to be speaker I
mean 15 ballots nobody wants to go
through that but he's gotten a border
bill passed he's gotten a debt ceiling
passed
um a bill that you know now that they're
negotiating over this thing um but joy a
lot of people didn't think he would be
able to hold the Republicans together
even to do that but on the other side
let's let's stay with the president
because two-thirds of the country saying
it would be a disaster or setback for
their current president to be re-elected
that's got to be troubling for the White
House yeah I don't ever remember
president Trump polling under 90 percent
with Republicans going into 2020. even
with covet and all the other things that
were attempted to hang around his neck
when you look at Biden it's not about
being a character indictment I don't
think it's the hunter Biden story that's
pulling Biden back I think people are
concerned they're concerned he wouldn't
make it through a second term they're
concerned he's not with it right now and
that's not I'm not attacking him for his
age I'm saying these are real
conversations that people have so even
if you're a moderate or on the left if
you're going to challenge Biden you've
got to run to the left but can you
really run to the left of a guy who says
what other progressives saying yeah
we're for that that's what we'll do then
you run more moderate than him like
rfk's doing he's do or Junior and what
he's doing is he's holding that populist
space that Trump held for the
Republicans right I don't know that's a
winning strategy but it's enough to get
I mean when Trump first came on the
scene he was at 30 which is not a
majority it's just a majority compared
to 10 other people dividing up what's
left so maybe RFK has some traction
maybe he doesn't but it doesn't like the
Democrats are going to let anyone
challenge Biden in any meaningful way
outside of someone who comes in as a
complete outlier which is right which is
why RFK says that the style of the DNC
is like the Chinese style the Communists
yeah
isn't a Democrat anymore and I I
wouldn't really treated me that way I
mean I think I walk away as well
I believe that RFK is occupying a space
in the Democratic party where it's the
alternative to Biden but not about his
platform you guys know more about what
RFK is talking about Democrats
it's not whether Democrats want the RFK
Junior voters won't go to buy and if
they have a choices whether they still
they're going to they're not saying like
three percent Tyrus how how do we solve
all the world's problems how do we solve
all the world's problems well we take
them one at a time we actually deal with
them the bad news is is
President Biden has nothing to do with
Democratic party we saw the G7 the state
he's in that speech was was painful to
watch and had nothing to do with
politics we see a deteriorating old man
period uh who's running for Democrat
right now is irrelevant they're they're
they're they're not gonna Kennedy's
never gonna get there Gavin Newsom will
probably when the time is right and the
time is not right right Gavin Newsom
he's starting to do things he's starting
to take positions that are more in the
National and California way but the
bottom line is and the thing with 97
days he McCarthy wants to negotiate with
the president it's not going to happen
you can't negotiate without we see the
state of his speeches everything he does
is controlled when he gets into
situations when he's asked questions
that's when we see the deterioration
he's not going to run again he can't but
here's the deal wait you're saying he's
not going to run this this campaign I
think eventually he's not going to but
there's a thing even even Biden
even a deteriorated Joe Biden would
still get votes because as long as it's
Trump because it'll be I will vote for a
deteriorated Biden before I will vote
for Trump so as long as Trump's in it
Biden's in it if for something happens
and Trump goes out look for a big change
and that's where you see Newsome but
okay
yeah what do you think well I've been
saying for a long time I think that
Biden's not going to make it to the end
and that Michelle Obama will be brought
in after all the Obamas are pretty much
running this Administration
we got to think if it's going to be an
Obama Newsome or Newsom Obama I think I
mean commercials
every single time
okay all right you've heard the
predictions here you saw him take a tour
of the house he checked out the curtains
Imagining the curtains that's what
happens okay
if I leave home on the road man goes to
my house no I'm gone and he's checking
out the house he starts talking to my
kids about his moral compass uh that
man's making a move yeah boy you heard
it here okay hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else